vous vous demandez sans aucun doute
pourquoi je suis venu jusqu'ici pour
arborer comme ça devant vous une
bouteille d'eau sale et franchement la
question est bien légitime est en fait
la réponse est toute simple
à partir de cette bouteille d'eau je
voudrais vous raconter une petite
histoire
alors imaginez qu il est 5 heures 45 et
quelque part sur un autre continent la
petite annie face réveil hanifa elle a 7
ans elle a deux petites soeurs une de 3
ans et demi une de 5 ans et de grand
frère et sa grande fierté dans la vie
c'est qu'elle est responsable avec sa
maman du bien-être de toute la famille
vers 6h30
elle a fini justement d'aider sa maman a
préparé quelques petites tâches et elle
se met en route avec sa tante qui habite
la maison juste à côté pour aller
chercher de l'eau elles vont marcher
pendant quatre kilomètres sous un soleil
déjà brûlant
deux jerricans vides à la main et quand
elles vont arriver au point d'eau même
si elles sont partis assez tôt elles
vont déjà trouvé devant l 47 femmes qui
elles aussi font la queue pour avoir
accès à l'eau alors ce parcours and i
fall le fait deux fois et quand elle va
rentrer chez elles sur les coups de
11h30 12h avec toute souriante
parce que elle a déchargé sa maman du
fardeau de l'eau et ça en fait celle au
canif à ramènera alors je sais pas ce
qu'il en est pour vous mais
personnellement je regarde cette eau et
je me dis que je ne voudrais pas mes
plantes avec cet os je laverai peut-être
même pas ma voiture
et pourtant c'est au hanifa et sa
famille l'a boiron ils cuisineront il se
laveront avec bref ils survivront
jusqu'à demain jusqu'à ce que ni fard
tourner chercher de l'eau alors pour moi
hanifa elles représentent ces héros du
quotidien ceux qui ne font pas de bruit
ce qui ne font pas de vagues les
silencieux mais vous savez quoi
il est des héros dont on se passerait
bien parce que pendant que hannifin elle
va chercher de l'eau
là pas de loisirs
et pire que ça elle va pas à l'école
elle va pas à l'école
ça veut dire que hannifin elle aura pas
de diplôme elle aura pas de diplôme
n'aura pas de travail elle n'aura pas de
travail n'aura pas d'indépendance
financière et finalement sa vie elle est
toute tracée
elle restera cantonnée comme sa tente au
rôle d'aller chercher de l'eau et on
voit bien avec la petite histoire dany
fin c'est le cercle vicieux de la
pauvreté est issu de la paupérisation
des femmes auxquelles on assiste est
malheureusement le cas de la petite
hanifa vous en doutez eh bien il n'est
pas isolé
à ce jour ce sont plus de 750 millions
de personnes dans le monde qui n'ont pas
accès à l'eau potable 750 millions de
personnes
nous sommes à peu près 7 milliards c'est
nul en calcul on va dire à peu près en
voyant large que ça fait une personne
sur huit à l'échelle de ce théâtre
environ 60 personnes sur ces 500
personnes vous pourriez faire partie de
ces soixante personnes qui n'ont pas
accès à l'eau potable
et là ce sont les chiffres officiels
après faut encore voir les inégalités
entre les hommes et les femmes entre les
zones urbaines et les zones rurales
entre les populations les plus riches et
les populations défavorisées bref
l'accès à l'eau est un révélateur de
toutes les inégalités dans le monde
et la situation ne va pas s'arranger à
l'avenir si rien n'est fait parce qu'on
le comprend bien
l'eau n'est pas une ressource infinie et
plus que tout l'eau n'est pas une
ressource substituables un jeu peut très
bien remplacer le charbon par du pétrole
le pétrole part du nucléaire le blé par
du riz le riz par de l'avoine ce qu'on
veut mais l'eau je le remplace par quoi
l'eau je la remplace par rien toujours 2
selon les nations unies
d'ici à 2025 ce sont plus de 1 milliard
800 millions de personnes qui pourraient
vivre en situation de pénurie d'eau et
deux personnes sur trois qui pourraient
vivre en situation de stress hydrique
alors nous dans nos pays on se rend pas
forcément compte l'accès à l'eau c'est
devenu quelque chose de banal
on achète nos petites bouteilles de 50
centilitres d'eau à prix d'or mais ce
qu'on oublie c'est que l'eau eh bien ce
n'est pas un produit comme les autres
c'est avant tout et surtout j'ai envie
de dire un droit de l'homme
mais avoir le droit qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
c'est marrant parce que c'est peut-être
une des premières choses qu'on apprend
les enfants disent toujours j'ai le
droit madame et j'ai le droit et bien
avoir le droit tout simplement c'est
bénéficier d'autorisations a priori
d'agir ou encore une autorisation a
priori de bénéficier d'un d'un bien d'un
service ou d'un état en d'autres termes
et bien vous n'avez pas à vous justifier
devant une quelconque autorité pour
réclamer un bien ou un service vous
n'avez pas à établir un plaidoyer en
douze chapitres pour démontrer que vous
avez le droit à la vie par exemple donc
finalement les droits de l'homme ce sont
ses droits inhérents à chaque être
humain dès qu on est on est avec ses
droits de l'homme qui sont ces
autorisations a priori qui nous permette
de vivre une vie digne et normal alors
bien évidemment l'eau est un droit de
l'homme
mais bizarrement c'est un droit qui n'a
été reconnu que récemment c'est en 2010
que l'assemblée générale des nations
unies et le conseil des droits de
l'homme des nations-unies toujours ont
reconnu le droit à l'eau et l'on définit
en disant que le droit à l'eau consiste
en un approvisionnement suffisant
physiquement accessible et de coût
abordable d'une eau salubre et de
qualité acceptable pour les usages
personnels et domestiques de chacun
alors à grands traits donc le droit à
l'eau qu'est ce que c'est le droit à
l'eau c'est tout d'abord une certaine
quantité et d'après l'organisation
mondiale de la santé c'est entre 50 et
70 litres d'eau par jour et par personne
pour mener une vie normale et ne pas
tomber malade et quand j'entends ces
chiffres 50 à 70 litres par jour je
réalise la chance que j'ai si je refais
un peu le parcours de ma journée je me
lève le matin je vais aux toilettes je
tire la chasse d'eau vous savez combien
de litres d'eau on gaspille quand on
tire la chasse d'eau entre 10 et 12
litres bon en moyenne fut une fiche de 2
3 fois toilettes par jour 30 litres déjà
je fais ma vaisselle entre 5 et 15
litres je fais la vaisselle deux fois
par jour 30 litres d'eau je prends une
douche raisonnable 1 3 à 5 minutes entre
50 et 80 litres
je fais ma lessive entre 80 et 100
vingt litres et là maintenant j'imagine
avec mes 70 d'ovationner je me dis que
je fais pas grand chose avec 60 kg alors
l'eau c'est une quantité mais c'est
également une certaine qualité
en d'autres termes on a le droit à une
eau qui ne nous rendent pas malade et au
moment même où je vous parle et c'est
une honte
tous les jours ce sont 5000 enfants et
5000 adultes qui meurent de maladies
liées à l'eau et finalement c'est pas
étonnant quand on sait que ce sont deux
personnes sur cinq qui boivent une eau
qui n'est pas assaini donc une eau qui
est plein de petites de petit verre de
virus de bactéries qui provoquent
diphtérie choléra et autres maladies
dont on ne veut même pas savoir le nom
et pour la petite histoire également ce
sont des millions et millions de
journées d'école tous les ans qui sont
manqués par des enfants à cause de l'eau
qu'ils ont bu alors améliorer le droit à
l'eau c'est aussi avoir un impact sur
une multitude d'autres droits de l'homme
comme le droit à l'éducation
donc le droit à l'eau une quantité une
qualité mais également une certaine
accessibilité physique avoir un robinet
la maison c'est un luxe et ce luxe on
n'a pas tous mais quand on n'a pas un
robinet à la maison et bien selon les
nations unies toujours le prochain point
d'eau ne devrait pas excéder les 1000
mètres autour de votre foyer
et enfin et surtout j'ai envie de dire
avoir le droit à l'eau c'est avoir le
droit de pouvoir payer sa facture parce
que entendons nous bien le droit à l'eau
n'implique en rien qu'on a le droit à
une eau gratuite l'eau qu'on le veuille
ou pas ça a toujours un coût imaginez
une ville au milieu du désert comme las
vegas maintenant un immeuble 45 étages
et au sommet du 45e étage vous ouvrez le
robinet et la mira qui à de l'eau
potable moi je ne comprends toujours pas
comment ça marche c'est une véritable
prouesse technique c'est quasiment un
miracle donc qu'on le veuille ou qu'on
veuille pas un finalement de manière
directe ou indirecte
on finit toujours par payer l'eau mais
par contre avoir le droit à l'eau ça
implique que vous pouvez encore payer
votre facture d'électricité que vous
pouvez encore payer vos loisirs que vous
pouvez encore payé l'alimentation de vos
enfants leur santé leur éducation
donc en moyenne on estime que la facture
d'eau ne devrait pas excéder les 3% du
budget mensuel d'une famille
alors les états ont l'obligation de
mettre en oeuvre ce droit à l'eau ils
ont une obligation de respecter et
surtout ils ont une obligation de le
protéger et en disant de le protéger
c'est surtout des violations par les
tiers et là je pense surtout aux
compagnies privées
on le sait bien qui par leur mode
d'exploitation laisse les terres exemple
un peu partout à travers le monde et
malheureusement malgré sa reconnaissance
en 2010 et bien le droit à l'eau demeure
trop souvent ignoré si ce n'est trop
souvent bafouée et c'est le moment où
vous dites c'est bien triste tout ça
mais moi qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je
peux faire et ça me fait toujours penser
à cette petite anecdote de mon enfance
quand j'étais petit que je finissais pas
mon assiette
mon grand-père musée pense aux enfants
qui n'ont rien à manger et l'or on a
tous entendu cette phrase moi ça mérite
et terriblement j'avais envie de lui
dire mais tu veux que je fasse quoi en
fait je prépare un petit colis avec les
trois prendre pommes de terre les deux
grains de riz les trois branches
d'épinards gym et en adresse enfants
quelque part dans le monde qui a faim et
j'en vois ça et on pourrait se dire la
même chose avec l'eau vous savez quand
par exemple on prend une douche et un
peu trop longue plein coeur de l'hiver
c'est douce et confortable c'est par
minute consignes on est sous l'eau
chaude on commence à culpabiliser envie
pourquoi j'ouvre un pipe line les gens
voient ça directement en afrique en asie
ou même en californie ça c'est un
réflexe normal mais en réalité on peut
toujours agir parce que si l'eau est un
droit de l'homme l'eau est également une
responsabilité partagée
un lot ne connais pas ce phénomène des
frontières et en tant que ressource
finie nous la partageons pas ce que
entendons nous bien le problème de l'eau
c'est pas un problème de quantité de
l'eau y en a c'est pour tout le monde
le problème de l'eau c'est comment on va
le partager comment va la gérer
comment on va la gouverner pour que les
partages soit équitable pour les
présentes et les futures générations
ainsi que pour sauvegarder nos
écosystèmes alors d'un point de vue
individuel bien évidemment ce qu'on peut
faire c'est déjà prendre conscience de
notre impact sur l'eau parce que bien
évidemment il ya ce que j'appelle l'eau
visible c'est facile de contre
andres je bois un litre d'eau je prends
une douche je fais ma vaisselle on
comprend mais à côté de cette eau
visible et toute cette eau virtuelle
qu'on consomme pour la petite histoire
pour un kilo de boeuf il faut 15 1500
litres d'eau gaspillée with est donc
l'équivalent d'une petite piscine pour
produire 1 9 seulement 1,9 et je parle
même pas un pur pour le déplacer un de
la ferme jusqu'au supermarché ou marché
ce sont 200 litres d'eau en résumé vous
faites une omelette de sens que vous
avez consommé votre mètres cubes d'eau
pour 1 kilo de pommes de terre se sont
590 litres d'eau est en fait partout à
travers le monde ce sont 70 % des eaux
douces qui sont utilisés pour
l'agriculture alors entendons-nous bien
je ne suis pas en train de vous dire
qu'il faut arrêter de manger c'est
surtout pas ça l'idée en revanche on
peut déjà prendre conscience de nos
modes de consommation et puis réfléchir
avec nos agriculteurs à des techniques
d'arrosage plus rationnelle et puis même
déjà notre échelle pourquoi pas
commencer par consommer nos légumes et
fruits de saison et puis nos légumes et
fruits locaux
après tout c'est peut-être pas pour rien
si les fraises ne poussent pas dans le
désert et puis ce qu'on peut faire
également
ces couples et notre prise de conscience
sur notre impact en haut avec notre
impact social alors cette photo là
derrière moi elle a été prise au
salvador il ya quelques mois dans la
municipalité de données par a c'est un
petit village et sa particularité c'est
que dans sa zone
hier sous les terres et à la cuy faire
le plus important du salvador le
salvador un tout petit pays en amérique
centrale et en 1996 une très célèbre
compagnie privée qui met de l'eau en
bouteille et qui produit du soda
d'ailleurs pour la petite histoire et
c'est choquant pour produire un litre de
soda ses 235 litres d'eau et bien cette
compagnie privée en 1996 elle a obtenu
le permis d'exploiter 20 millions de
mètres cubes par an d'eau alors si vous
êtes comme moi c'est à dire nulle en
chiffres ça vous parle pas en résumé
c'est 63 litres d'eau par seconde et on
sait à ce jour que si rien n'est fait
d'ici à 2030
y aura plus d'eau année par un plu doit
n'est pas ça veut dire plus de salvador
et déjà à ce jour les communautés
locales et surtout les communautés
indigènes ont de grandes difficultés à
avoir accès à l'eau potable
ce à quoi on leur répond et je ne
plaisante pas c'est véridique
on leur dit mais vous inquiétez pas de
l'eau il y en aura toujours on vous
vendra de l'eau en bouteille
vous imaginez c'est pas mal finalement
on vient chez vous on exploite votre
aquifères pour un prix dérisoire et puis
on va vous revendre un litre d'eau bon
mille fois son coût d'exploitation mais
vous inquiétez pas vous aurez de l'eau
alors malheureusement ce cas comme celui
du salvador il y en a un petit peu
partout dans le monde et bien souvent
ces compagnies privées dont je parle ce
sont des compagnies qui viennent de chez
nous alors non seulement nous pouvons
mais également nous devons exiger que
l'impact de ces compagnies sur les
droits de l'homme et le droit à l'on
soit davantage contrôler parce qu en
résumé l'eau c'est la responsabilité de
tous et que vous le vouliez ou non qu'on
le veuille ou non par nos modes de vie
par nos modes de consommation bien nous
avons un impact sur le droit à l'eau de
quelqu'un d'autre dans le monde alors
prendre conscience de son impact en nous
c'est bien exiger de nos politiques et
de nos propres compagnies privées
qu'elles traitent l'eau pour ce qu'elle
est c'est à dire un droit de l'homme et
non pas un produit c'est mieux alors par
contre je vais pas tarder à vous laisser
parce que j'ai parlé pendant déjà un
quart d'heure de tous et mètres cubes
d'eau et là va falloir que j'aille
heures enfin bon on avait un team je
peux vous dire un forget avait exercé
mon droit à l'assainissement bourse a le
droit à l'assainissement je vous en
parlerai une autre fois même si c'est
très lié au droit à l'eau mais je ne
partirai pas sans vous dire que dès
maintenant
eh bien nous pouvons tous agir et nous
pouvons être les héros de l'eau pour les
présentes et les futures générations
merci beaucoup